New Yorkers have decided to turn the Big
Apple into the Big Crapple.
They climbed to the top of Freedom
Tower, the new World Trade Center after
the previous World Trade Center
mysteriously disappeared.
They looked across the Atlantic Ocean
and saw London being rapidly transformed
into a Sharia compliant hellhole and
they asked themselves, "How can we make
that work here?"
And they realized that all they needed
was a mayor like Sadiq Khan, someone who
could play the fiddle as the city burns
to the ground.
Sorry, no fiddle. Music is haram.
But New Yorkers found someone even
better than Sadiq Khan. They found a
34-year-old Muslim socialist shouting,
"Free bus rides, free child care, and of
course, free Palestine."
Free, FREE PALESTINE.
>> FREE, FREE PALESTINE. FREE, FREE, FREE
PALESTINE.
ZOHRAN MAMDANI has absolutely no
credentials, but he does have an amazing
ability to combine every deranged
far-left policy you can think of with
Islamic supremacist victimhood
propaganda. And that, apparently, is now
enough to get you elected mayor of New
York City.
I wasn't terribly interested in this
meteoric rise of Mamdani. I actually
thought it was kind of funny in a you
asked for it, New York, and now you're
going to get it kind of way.
But then I saw that Congresswoman
Rashida Tlaib posted this.
Our joint statement on the vile
anti-Muslim racist attacks on Zohran
Mamdani. Muslim American members of
Congress call out vile anti-Muslim
racist attacks on Zohran Mamdani. Today,
Representatives Rashida Tlaib, Ilhan
Omar, Andre Carson, and Latifa Simon,
all four of whom exhibit that same
fascinating Islamist and far-leftist
that we see oozing from Mamdani,
released the following joint statement.
The vile anti-Muslim and racist smears
from our colleagues on both sides of the
aisle attacking Zohran Mamdani cannot be
met with silence. These hateful,
Islamophobic, and racist tropes have
become so entrenched and normalized in
our politics.
We know these attacks all too well. At a
time of increased violence against
elected officials, we cannot allow the
attacks on Zohran Mamdani to continue.
They directly contribute to the ongoing
dehumanization and violence against
Muslim Americans. We unequivocally
reject the normalization of anti-Muslim
hate and fearmongering and call on
elected leaders across our country to
speak out.
Now, when I see a congresswoman pulling
the vile anti-Muslim racist,
Islamophobic, violence, dehumanization,
fearmongering card from the bottom of
the desperation deck, I start wondering
why she's trying so hard to manipulate
people into keeping their mouths shut.
Think about it.
Four Muslims who were elected to serve
in the United States Congress
are trying to silence critics of a
Muslim immigrant who's about to be mayor
of New York City by complaining about
how they're all being dehumanized and
persecuted in this racist, Islamophobic
country.
When I see something like that, I
automatically think,
"Oh, you don't want to answer the
criticisms, so you're trying to silence
the critics. Now you've got my
attention."
And when I thought more about Zohran
Mamdani, I realized that he's
significantly more dangerous than people
think. Because he's not just a toxic
mixture of two political ideologies that
destroy societies, he's the fulfillment
of a strange prophecy I heard shortly
after the 9/11 attacks from my dear
Muslim friend, Nabeel Qureshi.
Let's learn a little more about Zohran
Mamdani and then I'll tell you about a
very disturbing Muslim prophecy that's
about to be fulfilled.
But first, speaking of prophecies,
Muhammad told his followers in Sahih
Muslim,
"The hour will not begin until the
Muslims fight the Jews and the Muslims
will kill them until a Jew hides behind
a rock or a tree and the rock or tree
will say, 'Oh Muslim, oh slave of Allah,
there is a Jew behind me. Come and kill
him, except the gharkad, a thorny tree,
for it is one of the trees of the
Jews.'"
When it comes to Islamists, their main
target right now isn't New York City,
even though New York City is quite the
trophy.
Their main target is Israel. Conquering
Israel by any means necessary is the
main stepping stone on the way to
restoring the caliphate, hence the
endless terrorist attacks.
But as is so frequently the case when
terrorists do what they do, it's the
ordinary people trying to live normal
lives who suffer.
Many Christian families in Israel, for
instance, rely on tourism for their
livelihood. They have shops or
restaurants near important sites, so
there are usually plenty of customers.
Then there's a terrorist attack and a
war breaks out and no more customers.
How are mom and dad going to feed their
kids?
This is what we call economic jihad.
Fortunately, there's a way you can help.
There's a company called Artza that
comes up with a new Bible theme every
few months and gathers products around
that theme from local artisans in
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem and
other locations and ships them to you in
a box. If you sign up with Artza, you'll
get candles, Israeli spice mixes, olive
wood carvings, mosaic art, decorations,
cosmetics, candy, soaps, jewelry, games,
all kinds of things straight from the
land where Jesus walked, delivered right
to your door.
There's a new theme every season, four
new boxes every year.
So, click the link in the description
box and sign up for a quarterly Artza
box. You'll be helping people out during
difficult times and getting some awesome
items in return.
Now, back to New Dearborn City. Sorry,
New York City.
There are two political ideologies that
never manage to create societies that
anyone actually wants to live in,
Islamism and socialism.
But for some reason, people keep
thinking that if we simply combine these
two political ideologies that bring
nothing but delusion and destruction,
we'll somehow get a utopia.
But let's face it.
Combining Islamism and socialism and
thinking it will produce a good
political system is like combining
bleach and rubbing alcohol and thinking
it will produce a good energy drink.
Islamism and socialism, as disastrous as
they are individually, do not mix well
because they make very different, even
contradictory, claims about how to
govern.
So, when we hear about an Islamist
socialist going into politics, we might
wonder,
is this guy an Islamist pretending to be
a socialist or a socialist pretending to
be a Muslim?
Some people think Zohran Mamdani is an
Islamist pretending to be a socialist.
Why would they think that?
Well, they noticed that his talking
points when he's speaking to Muslims are
sometimes different from his talking
points when he's speaking to
non-Muslims.
He always talks about making New York
City affordable, but when he's speaking
to Muslims, his message is also about
Muslims needing to have more political
power and about Islamophobes trying to
keep Muslims from having more political
power.
I am proud to stand here as the first
Muslim elected official to ever run for
mayor in the history of New York City. I
am proud
to be a Muslim candidate running for
mayor. As we all know,
to be a Muslim in public life
is to open yourself up to being called
whatever it is that someone may desire.
The first day I launched the campaign, I
was called a terrorist. Those attacks
have only increased and Andrew Cuomo has
started to send pieces of mail to voters
across the city of New York
that have artificially darkened and
lengthened my beard.
Alhamdulillah, there are a million
Muslims in this city.
200,000 of us are registered to vote as
Democrats. With early voting starting
tomorrow,
it is an opportunity,
an opportunity for us to show that
Muslims don't just belong in New York
City, we also belong in City Hall. This
election is one where we can finally
decide if we want to see ourselves in
our own politics. And like poor,
persecuted Congresswoman Rashida Tlaib
and poor, rich, persecuted Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar, he's really quick to pull
the Islamophobia card.
Growing up in the shadow of 9/11, I have
known what it means to live with an
undercurrent of suspicion in this city.
I will always remember the disdain that
I faced, the way that my name could
immediately become Muhammad.
To be Muslim in New York is to expect
indignity.
The dream of every Muslim is simply be
treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
And yet for too long
we have been told to ask for less than
that and to be satisfied with whatever
little
we receive. There are still certain
forms of hate that are acceptable in
this city.
One can incite violence against our
mosques and know that condemnation will
never come.
More than 1 million Muslims in this city
existing all while being made to feel
as if we are guests in our own home.
Some of Mondani's rap songs from his
short-lived rap career have resurfaced.
I've listened to a couple of them and
I'll just say that whatever you think
this guy will do as mayor of New York
City
whether you think he's going to burn
this city to the ground or turn it into
a paradise of free everything
we can all agree that Zohran Mamdani
will be a far better mayor than he ever
was a rapper.
His song Salam begins with this.
Wa alaykumu as-salam.
After saying as-salamu alaykum in an
auto-tuned robot voice a bunch of times,
he starts rapping about his fui, his
aunt.
He says he's worried about his poor aunt
because she's a Muslim who lives in
racist New York City.
Thinking of my fui, a hijab on her head.
What will she face? What will be done
and said? Turns out she's too scared to
leave her apartment or ride the train
because of all the Islamophobes.
She doesn't walk outside, doesn't ride
the train cuz she's terrified of the
coming pain. I don't want to keep
torturing you like this, so I'll just
read the lyrics.
Thinking of my fui, my aunt, her hijab
on her head. What will she face? What
will be done and said? Fear Fear It
never ends. A glance, a word, who knows
what it will portend? She doesn't walk
outside, doesn't ride the train
cuz she's terrified of the coming pain
from the words, looks, grabs, and
shoves. Man, she knows not who to trust.
Zohran was so deeply affected by his
aunt's fear that he continues using it
as he campaigns to become the mayor of
the city that treated her so terribly.
I want to speak to the memory of my aunt
who stopped taking the subway after
September 11th because she did not feel
safe in her hijab.
Of course, Zohran's critics pointed out
that his aunt didn't live in New York
City at the time and that she didn't
even wear a hijab.
So, he had to clarify that he was really
talking about his father's cousin whose
fear of riding the subway in her hijab
only came to an end because she died.
I was speaking about Zehra Fui
my father's cousin
who sadly passed away a few years ago.
Thank you, Zohran Mamdani, for letting
us know about all the New York City
Muslims who are too scared to leave
their apartments or ride the train
because of all the racist, Islamophobic,
hate-mongering bigots in New York City,
the most evil city on the planet.
But I have a quick question.
Are Muslim women in New York City really
being horribly harassed and abused by
random New Yorkers?
Were they being terrorized after 9/11?
There are more than 750,000
Muslims in New York City and more than
1.5 million Muslims in the greater New
York metropolitan area.
Are people
pestering them
assaulting them
persecuting them?
Zohran says there are Muslim women who
live in constant fear because New York
City is such a dangerous place for
Muslims.
If you simply step outside wearing a
hijab, New Yorkers will savagely abuse
you.
It's like the reverse of Iran where they
savagely abuse a woman for not wearing a
hijab.
Only difference is
it's not imaginary in Iran.
Now, think about the hypocrisy here.
If a Christian woman said after 9/11
I'm scared to leave my apartment because
Muslims just killed thousands of people
and I'm worried that Muslims might kill
me.
How would Zohran respond?
He'd call her a racist, Islamophobic,
hate-mongering bigot. How dare you be
afraid of Muslims in general?
If a Jewish woman in New York said today
I'm scared to ride the subway because
there are Muslims screaming globalize
the intifada
and I'm worried that Muslims are going
to kill me.
How would Zohran respond?
He'd call her a racist, Islamophobic,
hate-mongering bigot. How dare you be
afraid of Muslims in general?
But if a Muslim woman says I'm scared to
leave my apartment in New York City
because of all the non-Muslims out there
who are going to abuse me because I'm
wearing a hijab
how would Zohran respond?
He'd say
Look at what
the Islamophobes
have done to this poor woman.
The only way for this city to atone for
the fear it's caused this woman
is to elect her nephew or rather her
cousin's son
to be the next mayor
of New York City.
I got threats on my life.
Let me put this differently.
If a Christian woman or a Jewish woman
says she's scared of Muslims
is that a rational fear or an irrational
fear?
Zohran would say it's an irrational
fear.
But if a Muslim woman says she's scared
of non-Muslims
is that a rational fear or an irrational
fear?
Zohran would say it's a rational fear
and that the Muslim woman must be
protected at all costs, mainly by
demonizing anyone who questions or
criticizes Islam and by making her
cousin's son mayor of New York City.
Some fears are apparently more valid and
important than others.
Inequality is built into Islam.
Don't take my word for it. Surah 98,
verse 6 of the Quran.
Verily, those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
from among the people of the scripture,
Jews and Christians, and al-mushrikun,
mushrikun are people who associate
partners with Allah
will abide in the fire of hell. They are
the worst of creatures.
Jews, Christians, and other non-Muslims
are the worst of creatures. We're lower
than pigs, according to the Quran.
So, who cares what a Jewish woman or a
Christian woman is scared of?
But Surah 3, verse 110 says that Muslims
are the best of peoples ever raised up
for mankind.
Muslims are the best of peoples. Their
fears matter.
Just ask Zohran.
So, non-Muslims who are scared of
Muslims are irrational bigots. Muslims
who are scared of non-Muslims are tragic
victims of a racist population that
oppresses minorities.
By the way
who's this coming from?
Zohran Mamdani.
Zohran's father is a professor at
Columbia University.
His mother is an Oscar-nominated film
producer.
And he's about to be the next mayor of
New York City.
This is a family of immigrants.
One's a professor at an Ivy League
school.
One's a filmmaker.
And one's about to be mayor of a city of
more than 8 million people.
And Zohran can't stop complaining about
how Muslims are being horribly oppressed
in this Islamophobic, hate-filled
country of racists and bigots.
Why do people like Zohran Mamdani, no
matter how many blessings are showered
upon them in America
keep complaining about the horrible
oppression of Muslims here?
I mean, if Muslims really thought that
America is a terrible place for them,
why would they want to move here?
They want to move here for the same
reason lots of other people want to move
here.
It's just way easier to be successful in
the United States than it is in many
other countries.
So, why is Zohran obsessed with
portraying Muslims as victims?
Because portraying yourself as a victim
is the easiest and most effective way to
manipulate Americans.
If you want Americans to vote for you,
even when you have absolutely no
qualifications.
If you want to block criticism, even
when you support terrorists,
all you have to do is weaponize people's
good intentions.
People want to help a victim.
So, if you want to take advantage of
them,
be a perpetual victim.
Zohran Song Salam is a masterclass here.
Certainly not a masterclass on how to
rap. It would be more like a masterclass
on how to add a C to the front of rap.
But, it is a masterclass on stirring up
sympathy right before promoting
terrorism.
So, Zohran begins his song Salam by
telling everyone about his aunt, later
clarified as his father's cousin Zera.
We'll call her Auntie Zera.
Auntie Zera was too scared to leave her
apartment because New York City is so
racist and Islamophobic.
He starts with that.
Then, once he's got his dozens of fans
enraged at all the racist New Yorkers
abusing Muslims, he says,
[Music]
"My love to the Holy Land Five. You
better look them up."
[Music]
Okay, man. We'll look them up. Just stop
rapping.
From The New York Times,
the five defendants, all leaders of the
Holy Land Foundation for Relief and
Development, based in Richardson, a
Dallas suburb, were convicted on all 108
criminal counts against them, including
support of terrorism, money laundering,
and tax fraud. The group was accused of
funneling millions of dollars to the
Palestinian militant group Hamas, an
Islamist organization the government
declared to be a terrorist group in
1995.
Who are the Holy Land Five? The Holy
Land Five are a group of five
Palestinian-American Muslims who were
sentenced to a total of 180 years in
prison for running a charity that
collected donations in the US and
funneled these donations to Hamas.
The next mayor of New York City says
he loves those guys.
[Music]
But, you can't criticize him for
supporting the Holy Land Five because if
you do,
you'll be just like the Islamophobes who
kept terrorizing his poor auntie every
time she tried to ride the train in New
York City.
See, if you convince people that you're
the real victim, you can get away with
almost anything.
Just ask the Pakistani grooming gangs in
the UK.
If you're the real victim, you can even
get away with hanging out with Imam
Siraj Wahhaj, who's an unindicted
co-conspirator in the 1993 bombing of
the World Trade Center.
Imam Siraj has some powerful advice for
young Muslims like Zohran Mamdani.
[Music]
[Applause]
Politics can be a weapon to use in the
cause of Islam. It sure can be.
So, is Zohran Mamdani an Islamist who's
pretending to be a socialist in order to
win votes and pave the way for the
Islamization of New York City?
I don't know.
It would fit the previous pattern of
Twelver Shia. Zohran is a Twelver Shia.
Twelver Shias are the guys who took over
Iran during the Iranian Revolution.
How did they take over Iran?
By forming an alliance with socialists
and communists.
The Twelver Shias, socialists, and
communists formed an alliance.
They drove out the Shah.
They celebrated their victory.
And then the Twelver Shias executed the
socialists and communists.
So, an Islamist aligning himself with
socialists and communists to take down a
common enemy would fit the Twelver Shia
MO. But, socialists and communists also
want Muslims on their side. So, Zohran
could be a committed socialist or
communist using Islamic talking points
to get Muslims to vote for him.
Not enough to go on yet.
It's always a concern when we see
someone who's been handed everything in
life moaning and wailing about being a
victim.
And it's a bigger concern when we see
him openly praising a group of men for
funding a terrorist group.
There are also some other issues like
his response when he was asked to
condemn the phrase "Globalize the
Intifada." And he said, "Well, it's not
the language I would use, but
Intifada means uprising.
The Intifada in the early 2000s involved
lots of shootings and more than 100
suicide bombings, and it resulted in the
deaths of around 1,000 Israelis and
3,000 Palestinians.
When people on New York City college
campuses start screaming that this needs
to be globalized,
seems like something a future mayor
should condemn without qualification.
Unless he actually supports it or he's
worried about upsetting his voters who
support it.
But, here again, an Islamist, a
socialist, or a communist could all run
a campaign like this while trying to get
political power.
You don't always know where they really
stand until they get the political
power.
But, what Zohran really is doesn't
matter a whole lot for two reasons.
One, Islamism, socialism, and communism
would all be catastrophically bad for
New York City.
Pick your poison. Any one of them leads
to a disaster here.
Two, no matter Zohran's loyalties lie,
this guy becoming mayor sends a
dangerous message to jihadis.
My concern here is based on three
pictures I saw 24 years ago while I was
in college.
My best friend back then was a Muslim
named Nabeel Qureshi.
Nabeel eventually became a Christian, so
I had him send me the pictures for
occasions just like this.
A few months after the September 11th
attacks, Nabeel showed me some pictures
that were being passed around by his
Muslim cousins and friends on the
internet.
Nabeel thought they were absolutely
hilarious.
First was a picture of then President
George W. Bush as a Muslim, and I have
to admit that one was pretty funny. Old
W. looked like he had joined the
Taliban.
The second was a picture of the Statue
of Liberty with Lady Liberty's face
covered by a veil.
That picture wasn't so funny. It was the
Statue of Liberty, a symbol of freedom
and justice, covered by a full veil, a
symbol of oppression and Sharia law.
Now, those two pictures made their way
around the internet. So, lots of people
have seen them.
But, the third picture is the one that
was a bit more disturbing, and for
whatever reason, Muslims kept this one
to themselves. So, it didn't gain much
attention.
I'm talking about a photoshopped picture
of New York City covered in mosques and
minarets.
In the bottom corner, it said, "New York
City, 2006."
It was supposed to be a postcard from
the future.
Again, this was 2001, shortly after the
9/11 attacks. But, the postcard was from
5 years in the future.
The idea was that in just a few years,
New York City would be dominated by
Islam.
The terrorist attacks had cleared the
ground for the construction of new
mosques, and they led to an eventual
victory.
So,
this was a prediction, a prophecy, if
you will.
There were Muslims who believed that the
9/11 attacks would somehow, by the power
and wisdom and plan of Allah, lead to
Muslims taking over New York City.
They were off on their timing by almost
20 years, but it looks like they were
correct.
And they are going to be very, very
encouraged by Zohran's victory, no
matter where his ultimate loyalties lie.
New Yorkers are voting to send a
message.
And the message is,
"Hey, jihadis, you were right about us."
Nearly 25 years after 9/11, we're
handing control of the city to a Muslim
who really, really doesn't seem to have
the best of intentions.
Dangerous message.
And that's why Zohran Mamdani is more
dangerous than you think. He's the
fulfillment of a 24-year-old prophecy
about 9/11 leading to the victory of
Islam over New York City.
You asked for it, New York.
And now you're going to get it.
[Music]
>> Hey.